let me take a look at the code really quickly here you say off the pod research
and then you know we're going to do it right away yeah we're going to look right now
all right we're rolling okay cool that was a an interesting way to start yeah my phone i'm trying
to record on my phone today um because i'm i'm not at home and uh like my phone was overheating
and then it got like it went on vibrate mode but then it just didn't stop vibrating so it's
just a constant it kind of sounded like a like a razor yeah yeah it's crazy like right as we started
your phone just immediately like i could hear it just like just vibrating who knows it may explode
during this episode and then i'll switch to my other webcam but yeah i figured i'd give it a shot
awesome awesome dude how's it going you adjusted back to normal life from the live hacking event scene
uh not really no no i i've been i've been pretty still in the fall i was not yeah still in the fall
out not feeling uh super great yet i think my sleep is still like adjusting and uh it was weird because
when i was traveling i don't know if this happens to you but i'm sleeping like three maybe four hours a
night like oh my gosh for like two weeks straight and i was functioning like totally i would die like i
i would totally die even like looking back i was like in the moment i was like i have no idea how i
slept four hours last night because i don't feel like it and i was just like going through a whole day
like not sleeping until like 3 a.m and then i'd wake up at like 7 30 and like be fine and then i got home
and i've been sleeping more than i usually do like seven and a half hours and i feel like terrible i'm
like trying to like figure out i have no idea how you do that because i i mean i did that maybe one
night maybe i got like a six and i was still doing fine the next day and i was like all right you know
circadian rhythms hacked um but no if i get less than six i'm i'm done for my dude for sure yeah i mean
that's normally how i am like anything less than six and i'm i'm doomed even like i mean anything more
than six doesn't really seem to help me either um i generally like have pretty bad sleep so even if i
sleep like eight and a half hours in the night or something which never happens for me but i probably
just still feel the same wow so it kind of just takes like a couple hours for me to like fully wake up
and then i'm i'm like good to go i definitely need it's like a slow i definitely need more than six
though like six is like i'm skating by and then like seven or eight it's like all right i'm feeling
rested let's go let's go get it so i don't know yeah i was hoping that magically when i got home i
would like then be a night person and i would be able to stay up till 3 a.m and sleep four hours a
night and get a bunch more work done but no no i am immediately back to like ah it's nine o'clock it's
it's time for bed you've done a sleep study right yeah yeah and that really didn't like give me the
answers i was hoping for like i think for everybody it's a little bit different but when i got my sleep
study done they basically were like yeah you like you snore a little bit and you might want to look
into that i was like that's it they're like yeah that's it good luck i was like like what the heck
like what am i supposed to do with this so yeah i think for everybody it's a little bit different but
you know sleep study if you can get your insurance to cover it definitely i'd recommend getting
one done just to like have the have the analytical data and like the input from a sleep scientist about
what's going on for sure my dad had one done and he had uh you know got a cpap machine or whatever
and it like totally changed his life so yeah yeah yeah yeah cool anyways um security off the sleep
and into the security right um so yeah so the first link i had in the news section for today was
uh once again another banger from the asset note team and i'll give credit where credit's due this time
this is not shubs even though it has asset note written on it this is actually dylan pinder which
is a uh who is a security researcher researcher at asset note um and this is about the share file rce
which is actually a product that i've used fairly extensively so i was like oh what the heck is going
on here this is crazy how simple this rce was it's a beautiful exploit but um you know the other stuff
coming from asset note a lot of times has been a lot more challenging than this one looked
yeah yeah i mean it's always they're always anytime you see a blog post from asset note it's always
very high quality and it goes into a ton of detail about like their thought methodology and the path
that they took to get there and they do a really good job of explaining sort of like the attacker mindset
as they're coming towards something that like from the title you can tell is very severe um you know it's an rce
so i think that provides sort of a unique insight and oftentimes it's not like this super straightforward
type of like oh i put like id like semicolon id yeah in in a core parameter and it pops you know like
it's usually a little bit more in depth and it goes into like how they discovered it and yeah files
that they were looking for and the patterns and stuff and i think like that's really useful because
a lot of times you see sort of like the black box approach where it's like i was just fuzzing this
endpoint i saw an interesting parameter i tried a command injection and it worked and that's it and
you don't really get the understanding for like what that looks like on the on the back end or like
the engineering side or like if you were doing source code review how that might um how that might look
and so i think uh it's really awesome to see the blog posts that they put out because they go into
that level of detail for sure as always i love the methodology in the write-up they they talk about
they dump all the files they they talk about um this this uh i guess function that's getting called to
parse the cookie set current principle from session cookie um which you know if you were just kind of
looking through the code you might assume that that is going to be something that does you know
an authentication check and in fact the title of that section they they titled authenticated but not
really um because that once you double click into that that you know that call it just skips over it
if it doesn't find the cookie that it was looking for um and so it's like okay well sort of that was going
to be an authentication check and there's some other pieces down the line where um you know you would
assume our authentication was was um was necessary but they kind of you know weave around out of those
and eventually end up finding a path traversal not in um let me see if i can find the name of the
parameter it's not in the parameter that you would think um here it is right here yeah so it's it's not in
the parameter that allows you to specify the path it's a it's a in the upload id parameter um and that
gets concatenated with the path a little bit later and even though the path is actually um sanitized uh
the uh upload id is not which meaning which results in the path traversal which allowed them to get
arbitrary file right so that was a really i think that was a really good method and then this one also
sort of has a little bit of an a a twist to it which is you need to have a a valid parent id within the
application and so that parent id um you might assume would be something you might have to have
like a valid folder or a valid um you know id of a folder or something but really they found that
all you have to do is have a um string that does not fail when it gets aes decrypted and so it doesn't
matter what that string is it's not used anywhere but if it if it is if it gets uh you know if it passes
the aes decryption then you're able to to do the attack so they they outline really well um how aes
works how um the pkcs 7 padding works and how they were able to use that to um really reliably guess a
value for this um parent id i think it was only 128 or 256 um tries that it took to brute force and then
they find a a valid value that will pop and result in them getting a shell so once again you know big
round of applause to the asino team they they killed it yeah yeah i think it's um it's really interesting
because this is a something that we talk about in app appsec a lot where it's like validation versus
verification and like total like a textbook example is jwt tokens where they're just checking is this a
valid jwt token not is the contents inside of the jwt token valid and so those are two very different
things like if you're just checking that this is a valid jwt token it can decode properly and that's it
and you're not actually checking who signed it or is the key correct and is the person who they're
saying they are in the jwt token actually who they are who they are like if you're not doing those
checks then that's where these little like weird weird edge cases because you might read through this
and i'm sure it's like whoever wrote this like didn't think that this was going to be an issue they
probably were like yeah just you know check if this is valid and go forward and that's not enough
you need to like also just verify like do that extra step and that that pitfall i think hits in
a lot of different areas uh yeah and you know this is just another example of you know in a big product
as well like just that classic kind of case where they checked it but they didn't fully verify yeah i
don't know about on the jwt front i kind of feel like that's the whole cell of the jwt though is that
like you know it should be sort of self-authenticating because it's signed by the you
know by the person that that has the private key right so you know and obviously that doesn't always
work out to be the case but um you know these different technologies do have their different
pitfalls and that is you know in the jwt scenario as you mentioned that if somebody does you know find
a way to forge a token or get their hands on the private key or whatever then you're just totally
screwed so yeah yeah so much of that comes down to like which library you're using too like if you're
just using a library that separates out like validation and verification then that might just
like put you in a big pitfall where you're using the built-in library or something but it has an extra
function that you needed to call and you didn't know it or something like that and that oftentimes
is just either a documentation problem or something even stupider than that and you know it it happens
to everybody so i think it's just uh you know it's cool to see it in the wild and i think it's just
something that you should always keep keep an eye out for and just like you know check and see are
they are they actually verifying my my jwt contents can i just give it any sign jwt and will it work
yeah so um i guess bringing it back to the blog post i did have one more thing that i'll just try to
explain from you know without you having to go and read the blog post which is like i've done a couple
deep dives on aes and um and you know the padding portion of it for padding oracle attacks so for
those of you that have done that in the past and want a little bit of a refresher the way that the
uh pk cs7 padding works is that you've got your you know you've got your 16 uh byte blocks and then
when you don't have when your data does not sum up to 16 bytes the rest of that 16 bytes is filled by
the value that is the number of remaining bytes so if you've got 15 uh you know bytes in that in that
block and you need to get one more that last byte is going to contain the a byte that points to one
and if it's you know 14 then it's going to have two yeah zero zero two zero two right um and so that
that's something that i had back there you know in in the memory database and that but just doesn't
come you know sometimes when i need it to so there's your little refresher on on um aes uh padding
protocol for any of you that are interested in that that low level of cryptography yeah yeah yeah you
probably see this a lot in ctfc like if you decrypt an aes block and it's not exactly the block length
then it'll always have like trailing bytes that usually are not printable because it's from like
zero x zero one to zero x zero f and so oftentimes you'll be like oh what is that oh right i need to
unpad it and there's like a some copy paste function that i always use off stack overflow to do that in
python yeah yeah no python man this is just another great example because the exploit here is written in
python is like you really if you're going to try to get to this level of you know pro hacking you need
to be pretty handy with python or you know some sort of scripting language so that you can just write
out these pocs pretty quickly yeah 100 all righty so let's see what else we got on list for today
um so uh bavook jane pretty well-known hacker uh he tweeted out on twitter uh when was this a couple
days ago um originally that they had like a full read ssrf in a headless chrome instance they were
trying to escalate it somehow they were trying a bunch of different things they could access gcp
metadata but the creds were super restricted so they couldn't really escalate that they tried a bunch
of different internal and external subdomains again couldn't really find anything useful couldn't
really escalate it asked for some help on twitter and today they re they quote tweeted their own tweet
and they said solved nice so the solution was that they figured out that they could hit the chrome
debugger instance on port 9222 uh on slash json specifically i believe um which will dump but i i
guess a lot of data about what's going on i've never actually used this port so i'm not super familiar
with how it works but he did link to some docs that describes like what this what this api is used for and
the type of data that that is provided there um and he said that it allowed exfiltrating data from
other users who were hitting the chrome uh the headless chrome browser instance so it seems that
it basically gives like an overview of all the data and stuff that's happening within that chrome browser
instance and uh that's a really awesome creative way to escalate that i think that's a default port would
be my guess the 9222 yeah that is a default port and i i threw this in the news articles for this week
because we've mentioned this on the pod before the um the debug instance there and it's great to see
someone actually pop something with it and that's um you know when you hit that slash json endpoint um
on the on the dev tools protocol it dumps a list of all of the uh available sort of web socket targets
that you can connect to for the dev tools protocol um and some of that stuff will leak information about
any other tabs that are open in the browser right so if you have other people using that headless chrome
instance then that could absolutely leak information about you know what what what page they're looking
at or what user information would be in there um so that's that's something that i hadn't i was i thought
about that route a little bit more for like accessing sort of chrome internals and being able to pivot
around a little bit from there but i actually didn't think about it just from like the raw
you know data being leaked via that slash json endpoint about other users so it's got sort of
an application level uh you know use as well when exploiting uh headless chrome instances yeah super
interesting and i think like it's also like a kind of unique thing where we've we've talked about headless
browsers specifically as well but um like it's it's a unique attack scenario where it's not it's like more
than an srf because you're in the headless browser specifically and so this is the type of functionality
that only exists in like certain scenarios but i think it's a good thing to put in your word list and
and to check for for sure let me go see if i can find the episode where we talk about that it's i want
to say it was one of the earlier on episodes where um yeah it was episode nine headless browser ssrf so we
talked about that that was a fun episode because those are such cool that's it's such a cool bug class
yeah yeah and live overflow replied to his his follow-up tweet and linked a video that live over
posted um just almost two years ago now august 19 2021 uh that talks about hacking a screenshot
service so live overflow made a screenshot like a headless browser screenshotting challenge for the
cyber security uh challenge germany in 2021 and then made a follow-up video about like how it worked how
to exploit it a bunch of different uh information about how you could go about escalating it and all
that kind of stuff and um uh buvuk replied to that tweet and was like oh yeah this is exactly what i did
so so i think it's really cool you know this shows if you you know follow live overflow if you follow the
content creators who are making awesome awesome content in the cyber security space a lot of the
time that will help you later down the road even if it's a video from two years ago yeah for sure man
i i've just started recently to appreciate i think fully how awesome live overflow is they do a lot of
really awesome content and really good methodology stuff too so i think i think uh you know i think as
as a hacker that sort of i don't know i feel like at this point i'm a little bit more focused on um you
know doing the hacking and doing the research and stuff like that rather than um you know consuming
content on cyber security um but i think i'm missing out a good bit because there's a ton of awesome
content creators that have kind of sprung up since i started bug bounty that i've kind of missed out on i
kind of missed the the start of their you know uprise and uh i think i got to go back and kind of do
do a little you know indexing of how awesome those people might be yeah for sure i mean there's so many
people who are creating amazing stuff um recently i can't remember their names but there's like one or
two people who i've noticed a lot uh in oh by the way your camera's completely frozen yeah i think i think
it just died i think it's done it hit it's right dude yeah oh no all right okay well i'll just keep i'll
keep talking or should you want me to pause no no go ahead you're good you're good continue okay cool
yeah so um no i just think that there's a lot of really uh really interesting awesome new talent that's
popped up into the hacking space not even specifically within bug bounty but just sort of like across the
board um and i think a good example is there's a couple hackers who i've noticed recently and i wish
i could think of their names off the top of my head or find them quickly but they've been posting
a lot of like hardware security type stuff one of them has been doing a lot of mobile hacking
where he's been taking especially these iot devices like smart plugs or smart cameras and stuff
and looking at how the mobile app is collecting that data where is it sending to uh you know what other
data might it be collecting alongside of that with location data and that sort of stuff um and another
one of them has been doing similarly a lot of like hardware stuff but more on the hardware teardown side
where they've been taking popular hardware devices or like i love that stuff dude um alibaba type
alternatives and tearing those apart and seeing like how does this work on the inside is this vulnerable
and you know x y or z way um and i think you know just putting that data out there and having it
somewhere that's readable in this case generally it's twitter threads um it makes for an awesome addition
to the security like learning community where now you have additional resources that you can pull on and
you can look at real world examples of how this type of stuff works yeah for sure man yeah i i love that
you know we kind of talked about this before but like teardowns and stuff like that man those things
are so helpful whenever you're trying to like you know figure out how a device is working i know i
really heavily relied on some of those for some of the live hacking events we've done and you just go
online and you find someone who has like you know broken it out and like linked all the uh
you know fcc like pages and stuff like that i'm just like oh gosh i love you yeah exactly yeah it's uh
i mean i think oh i did find one of them um hacks rob he's the one who's been doing a lot of the like
software side with mobile apps and figuring out how um how the how the app is collecting data and
where it's sending to and all that kind of stuff h-a-x-r-o-b r-o-b on twitter hacks rob
uh and then i wish i could find the other guy i know it starts with an a
uh we'll link it we'll link it down below but yeah um you know any any info info that you can put
out there just i'd recommend trying to put it out there i personally am not the best at this honestly
it's hard i'm more of like a i see a cool tweet and i retweet it instead of creating my own unique
content but um i think you know i love to see that stuff uh out in the space and and hopefully i can do
a little bit more of it myself i did find the other the other person it's atc1441 uh i believe
they also have a youtube channel which i think is how i originally found them i was just like on
youtube and out of nowhere this like hardware like tear down hacking video like popped up on
my feed and i was like wow that's like not something i see every day and i saw his video and it was like
really cool and then he showed up on my twitter feed as well so yeah atc1441 he's more of like a
hardware uh focused hacker i would say um his most recent thread was a couple days ago and he went over
this it's a called a data frog handheld emulator whoa what the heck it's very cheap it's on aliexpress
and it's like you know like a game handheld like emulator gameboy knockoff type type device you know
very cheap um but you know it was a teardown of like how it works what the chips are and that kind
of stuff and again like this type of just it doesn't have to be vulnerability research so much as just like
informational knowledge and research and just sharing that out publicly is super useful for future research
i think a lot of the time you'll see um i i mean this happened to me multiple times where i'm tearing
apart a hardware device i see a chip number i google that chip number and the second link is a blog
post that's titled reverse engineering the oh my gosh it's like i'm like oh this is perfect this is exactly
what i was looking for so honestly just putting that info out there is so useful um and it's it's
so great for future hackers even if it's you know just some random thing that you're looking at yeah
like we said before even if you don't get anywhere just like you know having gone through the process
sharing your knowledge is is super helpful but like you said as well it's very hard to do that you
know it's not necessarily the easiest thing in the world to do so um yeah that that could definitely be
that could definitely be something that if someone wants to sort of ease into content creation
that could be a great way to go yeah for sure um all right so sort of along the lines of iot
devices slash apple application you know physical applications um this next piece that i had in the
note was a tweet by orange which anytime orange tweets anything uh for those of you that aren't familiar
it's orange underscore eight three six one um yeah orange sigh on twitter uh you know this is
bad news yeah yeah bad news bears if you're if you're the target bad if you're if you're just a researcher
good oh hell yeah exactly you wake up and you you roll over and you read that blog post right away
so that's what i did and um yeah he he wrote up a version of it um talking about how uh this specific
google search appliance which is actually sort of like a on-prem version of google search which i
didn't know existed um they they kind of bought one on ebay and uh and pulled figured out a way to
get the the firmware um from like some old google group like you know weird google group that shouldn't
be public right which is just like the most hackery thing like that is what we talk about all the freaking
time and he goes in there and he's like okay you know here's a link to it oh sweet i can just like
iterate through these numbers and download literally every single version of the firmware and what's
great is like this is something i think i've done like i tried this before and it's it's not worked like
it's really awesome that this worked um but like basically he was like looking on on this forum thread
from like oh when was this uh 2015 or something oh my gosh somebody linked and they were like hey
i was trying to download this here's like the link but it's not working and so they took that link and
they like went on web archive and they figured out the valid like version number ranges and then they
just brute forced every potential file version like with that formatting on the same host and you know it
came back with actual files which is also kind of crazy because this whole this whole product google
search appliance looks like it would be extremely deprecated by this point but oh yeah i'm sure
uh maybe it's being maintained to some extent or maybe they still just have like versions of the
files up there or something but it's really really crazy that i i mean i had never even heard of this
thing i didn't even know it was a thing i've never seen a photo of one uh i didn't know google made
hardware like this so uh i think as a hacker if i had known this would it would have existed i would
have been like oh i want to get my hands on that yeah if you scroll down to the very end he has a
timeline um and it says that google said the issue is not severe enough to qualify for a reward and i'm
like are you kidding me this is rce but you know i i think that's probably because this product is not
being used you know or not being actively used by a large user base and so the risk is just not there
but yeah the the the bug itself the bugs the the flow is really really interesting so definitely worth
a read if you're interested in tearing apart iot devices and figuring out exactly how he does it and
also i just kind of love oh actually now that i'm going through it he's got some of this stuff censored
yeah no no but some of the stuff is not censored but if you scroll halfway down
he he starts he starts doing like he writes in the post like all right this is the contents of etsy shadow
this is like the password to like you know this config you know sort of thing i'm just like oh my gosh he
just totally wrecked it you know when you're like writing plain text passwords of these like embedded
devices all over the internet um super badass and also i just wanted to shout out i really do like the
way that he broke down the various network services that are listening on various ports the ip tables rules
that you know show access to those um and that sort of thing too that's a great way to sort of uh take a
an attack surface and you know get it in front of you feel like you're actually able to work within and
understand all your different attack vectors in your routes which really shows how he you know
developed that methodology and why he is so good at what he does you know and this is the whole team so
it's not just orange but this is his the um the research team that he's associated with yeah and even
like in a recent live hacking event i'm not gonna name anything but we saw an example of this exact
type of thing where it's more of attacking like an appliance uh like or an os type package than it is
like even a hardware device i because i think and i might be mistaken here but it seems like
most of this was from software analysis like they got a firmware they pulled it apart they
started figuring out like how does this os work what types of services are running where what's the
the attack surface all that kind of stuff and we've seen that even like you know recently in the last
you know month or two where that same type of thing exists in modern companies um including google
obviously um and i think it's just a really interesting attack surface i always love that
type of stuff where it's like it's it's right there like in your hands and you just have to figure
out like how it works and like pull it apart and and once you can figure out how the secret
sauce works then that's usually where where all the vulnerabilities live but i also love that in
the timeline the first the first entry of the timeline is a cbe from 2005 oh my gosh which is
it's like a code like java code injection yeah java code injection and it's a cbe from 2005 that links
to a secular you know disclosure back in the wild west days when this used to be like a mailing list
he's got like an at metasploit.com email hd more this guy this is legit so cool so cool yeah so
that's a it's just a really cool really cool blog post i'd recommend you give it a read just to
again this is one of those rare glimpses into like who i would classify as an elite hacker oh yeah for
sure i'm just like understanding that mindset and the thought process and the exploitation process and
the whole start to finish path of how do you take something as abstract as like a google search appliance
or like a server box or an os image and take it all the way to a vulnerability that you can then
report and get a bounty for oh yeah hopefully well yeah i'm not yeah in this scenario he may be hoping
to get a bounty but uh it doesn't look like they google came through on that one but um just for
those of you that don't get to go and read the blog post um the summary of what ended up happening
here was after like dumping all of the source code and getting access to the the um the firmware for
this uh the the vulnerabilities which are you know being exploited are actually very simple we just
you've got a basic lf injection um you know something's getting it's an art it's a command
injection in a specific parameter um where you just put you know your your um uh what is it is it oa yeah
it's oa uh percent oa in the scenario and then add another command right after it so it's just like a
very standard shell you know injection and then um and later on they've just got a very textbook
um uh lfi or lfd technically um and so these are also vulnerabilities that they were able to discover
and uh exploit from a remote perspective rather than you know interacting directly with the physical
device um so from an exploitation scenario you know from an exploitation perspective the bugs were not
like blow your mind crazy stuff like you normally see with orange and his research team but the
approach was really cool to breaking down a iot device and that was what i really appreciated about
this article yeah same all right last one for the um for the news segment and then we'll jump into the
to the content for this episode um bit quark finally after four years after four long years of waiting
has released short scan um their tool for uh exploiting the uh tilde tilde you know enumeration method
with um windows short names um so that's really exciting for those of you that aren't familiar with
that technique uh for specific iis servers actually a lot of iis servers um this can help you enumerate
the first i want to say it's like six characters of um any file and folder and then the first uh you
in the file extension for that or the first three characters of the file extension for those files and
folders um and so that's it's really helpful for when you're doing recon on iis environments and this tool
utilizes some new techniques to try to uh get you the full uh path the full file name not just the short
file name um which isn't present in a bunch of other tools that we use for this so i'm definitely
excited to give this one a poke next time i'm going after iis uh targets yeah so i believe this is on any
is uh 8.3 and earlier or maybe it's only 8.3 but um but yeah something like that no it's it's a ton of
them yeah they're like almost all of them are vulnerable to it by default i think yeah yeah so
i mean it's still definitely out there it's funny because i was just looking back at the original repo
from ursdl i think we actually talked about last episode we did yeah um yeah and uh he has like the og
tool for this is what i would say like i think i've been using this same tool since at least probably
since the beginning of when i started using this i believe chubbs was actually the one who told me
about this this vulnerability even existing um and if you look at the tool like the first uh well not
the first commit but there is a commit in the root of it from ursdl that is from nine years ago from
from 2014 my gosh and the title of the repo is is short name scanner 20 2012 to 2023 and still giving so
it seems like this has been uh you know there for a very long time um it's good to see new tools pop up
that can do stuff either faster or better or in a different way um you know as much as i love using
tools that are written in java i think i would prefer one that's written in golang so uh but that's not to
say that the original scan yeah yeah yeah exactly that's that's the nice thing so like the original
tool um is still you know being actively maintained there was a commit two days ago um and they actually
ursdl actually linked to bit quark's short scan tool in the in the is short name scanner repo the
original one so um i think it's awesome um you know it's awesome to see you know people still maintaining
this stuff and making sure it works and adding new vectors to make it quicker and easier to scan and
exploit so i'm not a huge recon guy as i've talked about on the podcast like i don't do a bunch of
recon but this is one of the techniques that if you skip this you're really missing some gold because um
like it like you know if you're just if you get a really finely tuned list that's great but if you're
actually able to leak the contents of like arbitrary names that is like freaking gold huge
i mean there's so much hidden functionality like just that alone like hidden functionality
web configs like um path reversals knowing knowing what files exist like all that kind of stuff is
you know super super critical like 99 of the time just on its own and so being able to have
that leverage that you can then exploit and know a path name or um maybe be able to access a file that
you shouldn't be able to access or anything like that um you know this this type of info is super super
helpful to have and i i think anytime i see an iis server um i typically run it because it's a super
easy win if it works and if it doesn't work it is very low cost yeah so actually when i was in the
recon game like i i actually i'll give this one away for you that are doing recon stuff but i would
actually have an automation that was would detect iis and then run this on every iis server that was
vulnerable and then just take the output and like look at it for like sort of sketchy stuff like dot
back files right like um you know backups or old files and you know and there's there's a bunch of
other uh regex that i had and stuff like that that would kind of trigger weird stuff but um yeah you can
find some really easy wins with like web config dot back or something like that um and this this uh tool can
definitely tip you off to it so keep that in mind and definitely check out bit quark's new tool yeah
for sure all right should we get our esoteric web vulnerabilities let's do it man um let me take a
sip of water first because i've got a bit of a sore throat and then we'll get into it we're gonna have
to move pretty quickly because we do not have uh we've got a lot of of stuff to cover and not a ton of
time but um yeah first up config file injection so while i drink this water tell the people about it
cool yeah so config injection file injection pretty much what you would expect and we talked a little
bit about this during the hardware episode i think yeah um but basically this is uh if you're working
with okay actually actually hold on let me let me let me just stop you really quickly okay so i i just
want to i just want to highlight this before we jump right into this okay so these volumes what we're
talking about today like we said like he alluded to these are esoteric web phones these are volumes
that are at the top of my list and in joel's as well in some part um that of volumes that i feel like
you probably don't know about that you should probably know about because i see these a lot
at live hacking events and i see these um you know in the wild and bug bounty quite a bit and having
these sort of tools in your belt uh really really helpful um so make sure you're paying attention
especially do these first couple ones because they're they're really really helpful okay yeah
sorry i wanted to want to give that probably fine joel go go get it okay yeah yeah yeah no and i'll
actually i'll tee off on that and say that um some of them are more common than others um this first
one probably not as common but some of the other ones definitely a lot more common and definitely a lot
more uh instances of it out there that i think you could exploit so for config file injection typically
this is going to be a case where maybe there's a configuration endpoint a lot of times this is on
iot devices or hardware devices or something more local because that type of stuff doesn't really get
you know revealed externally for like a web service typically it's not going to be writing to like
it's dhcp config or something like that from just like an api endpoint on you know example.com right
i've seen it i've seen it yeah yeah it exists that's not saying it's not there but it's a lot less
common and i personally have seen it significantly more often in like routers and smart devices and iot
whatever's right like that's typically where you're going to see it is in the those type of more like
niche devices that are much closer to like an api that's talking directly with the os or the system
versus an api that's talking to a service that's running on an os within a system um so
config file injections is when you can write stuff into the config file um oftentimes this i think in
order to exploit it successfully oftentimes you're going to need to have an understanding of what the
config file actually looks like so some type of file read or file disclosure um or access to the os or
error yeah verbose errors anything like that just to get an understanding for what the format is and
what stuff looks like around it i think a lot of these cases typically rely on like weird types of
parsing behavior for you to be able to exploit it so um one example is dns mask where dns mask if you
write multiple instances of certain directives within the config file it will basically ignore
the first instance and only read the second instance but that's not true for everything some
of the directives can only appear one time and so understanding is your value being written multiple
times is it being written one time how long is the line that it's being written into all those types
of things really matter a lot and so that's why having some sort of information or verbose
errors or access to the file system or something like that is really really helpful when you're
trying to exploit these successfully but they exist i think in a lot more cases than you might expect
and typically it's really just understanding what sort of weird functionality is built in and exists
that you can then exploit to your advantage so dns mask for example has this thing called tftp i did not
even know this was a thing until we exploited it that one time so tftp is like a weird service it's
kind of like ftp and it runs on what is it port uh i think it's part 69 yeah exactly yeah so it's
like you know super weird um and yeah you can basically specify like a file path and it operates
kind of like an ftp server in that you can just like read files sometimes you can write files um there are
weird permission checks and stuff but if you can inject into you know the system config file depending
on who this is running as what user this is running as then you might have full root arbitrary file read
through a completely separate port that wasn't even open or exposed initially but because you've made
changes to the config file it's now listening on port 69 and now you can hit you know the file system
and you can read etsy password or whatever yeah um yeah so so like you said you know it's very it's
very dependent on getting a good grip on where you're at in the system which is why you see people like
orange and and um and uh the acid note team whenever they're breaking down a target they always always
always try their absolute best to get their hands-on source code because if you can get your hands-on source code
you just get such a better understanding of what's happening and you can craft these crazy bones that
have these amazing outcomes um and this config file injection piece kind of like you said it's a
little bit rare but i feel like it's not that rare in that um like a lot of systems that are interfacing with
other services so you know in in the scenario that that we were just talking about with dns mask you know
maybe you're spinning up a dns server right and uh and you know you want to have dns mask active and so
you're dynamically generating that dns mask configuration file and that's where the injection
happens because you need to uh you know spin up that dns mask server with um user input as the
configuration file and so um you know situations like that whenever you're interacting with other services
there's a there's a high risk for this you know oftentimes you're injecting it via a template
um and you know the templating doesn't necessarily have the right control characters to prevent you
from escaping the block that you're in in the code um and we can use comments and stuff like that to
clean up after us so um oftentimes it's pretty easy to um inject into that configuration file your own
malicious input um and that can result in some crazy vulnerabilities but it's also going to result in
some crazy exploitation scenarios where you are reading the documentation more than you ever thought you
would be reading the documentation um and getting very very familiar getting very intimate with this
uh with this application with the configuration that you're injecting into and that just makes for
some crazy interesting and fun bugs yeah and it's so much more satisfying when it pops too because
it's like it's like you've gone through a whole journey just to get to that point and then
finally everything works and your payload works and you pop it and you know it calls back or whatever and
it's awesome it's an awesome feeling somebody asked me the other day what is what my favorite moment
hacking was and i had to put some thought into it and it but it was i think it was one of the bugs i
collaborated on with you when finally we shelled this this iot device i was just like oh my gosh i love
this so much yeah yeah it was amazing it was like a super culmination of of so much time and effort and
yeah the payoff is is super worth it yeah for sure so let me see if there's anything else um here that
we wanted to talk about um yeah so we i guess i'll you mentioned dns mask we've also seen this in dhcpd
uh nginx and apache um configurations uh injections so definitely be on the lookout for anything that's
sort of interacting with these services and keep um file or config file injection in mind next time
you're doing your next assessment yeah yeah exactly like if you see a dhcpd server it doesn't mean that
you need a zero day in dhcp or dhcpd like it doesn't mean like oh they're running the latest version so
it's not exploitable move on to the next thing there's no cve or whatever it's totally up to
configuration and how this stuff is working because it can be a perfectly regularly validly configured
instance but they're doing something wacky somewhere else within the system and you can exploit that
behavior to natively get a shell or escalate your privileges within the system and that that's
like the real powerful thing is this isn't like a zero day or anything this is just how you can
configure it legitimately to do weird stuff that we can take advantage of as an attacker yeah great
summary um next one that i had on the list was client-side path traversal now this one's a little
bit weird because you think of path traversal normally as a you know server-side sort of thing you're you're
putting something in either a query parameter or a path um and you directly in your url and you're
getting to access to some path that you that you didn't previously have access to by using some
iteration of dot dot slash or combination of dot dot slashes right um client-side path traversal occurs
when you are able to inject via a query parameter or a hash or something in the user's browser so you
know the users click the link or you've redirected the user to a specific spot um and that page is uh loading a
resource based off of your attacker based input so let's say for example you redirect them to
google.com slash example slash one two three four and they try to load a css page that that's like
slash css slash one two three four dot css right so your one two three four from the path is being taken
and put into a resource that's being loaded then you know if it's url decoding it and stuff like that
you can try to use some um path traversal sequences to hit a different part of the application hopefully
hit a redirect and get yourself a full css injection on that page which as as we all know from listening
to other episodes of critical thinking can result in some very critical stuff um so uh that's sort of
what i had on client-side path traversal you got any other thoughts on that joel yeah i mean this
isn't a client-side path traversal but i think one of the things that's kind of closely related to this
that i really like as a class of bug and this is kind of it's not really talked about a ton but i think
it's like path traversal through id and oftentimes i see this with like there's a post request that
includes an id in it for example there's say it's a posting a json body one of the parameters is id in
the body and it's a uuid or something well oftentimes you can put uid slash dot dot slash some other
arbitrary path some arbitrary internal path or something and that just gets fully concatenated
into an internal request and it's it's like in the line of ssrf kind of srf slash path traversal
but it's a really really interesting technique and i see it exploited all the time like all over
the place it's something that i now regularly check for whenever i see an id being sent is
let me just try putting a dot dot slash and then like the same id after it and just see if that still
works because that's often a really good indicator of whether or not it's working and that's kind of
um i don't know it's it's not quite esoteric it's a little more common but it's like a weird um
route for exploiting like srfs and kind of a server-side path traversal if you want to call it
that um and i think it it deserves being mentioned alongside this yeah for sure man i i've seen those
all the time and excuse me they're very impactful bugs if you can get them to work especially if you
understand what api is being hit in the back end or you have some introspection into that through the
error or something like that those are some crazy crazy bugs so and and then just to clarify the
reason why you're saying put so let's say we've got id or uuid equals you know one two three four dash
whatever then you put a slash at the end you put a dot dot slash right so that would delete the id you
just put in right yeah and then you put the same id again so that that path is should be normalizing to
the same thing it was without having the any of the path traversals in there right right and you can
imagine this in the backend scenarios basically like one service is hitting another service the way it
does that microservices yeah yeah microservices hitting it through an http request and it goes
you know other internal service dot host slash id or whatever slash api slash get slash id or something
right however you want to imagine how it's being put in there and then if you're giving it a full value
and it's not being sanitized and that's just being chucked onto the end of that url your path traversal is
going to affect that internal microservice call and be able to hit other api endpoints and other things
within that other service that you may not have been intended to to hit and i i see so much impact
approved from these all the time it's really insane some of the biggest uh baddest vulnerabilities
i've ever seen are caused by this and it's something that seems so simple and straightforward so
if you're not checking for that be sure to check for that because it's it's again it's it's not quite an
easy win but it's it's it definitely gives you a lot of leverage yeah and i think it's systemic on
the targets as well normally because the target is using a microservices based architecture so if you
find one you're likely to find lots of other unique issues as well with their own unique fixes
um and so i'll actually also link in the in the notes for this episode um that uh there's a blog
post by sam curry and i uh that did let's see when did we i'm not sure this is a long time ago that we
had done this um yeah i mean sam is like the king of this type of yeah he's the one who i like learned
it off of and i see so many crazy impactful bugs that are that are shown by him using this uh i i
wasn't sure which ones i i should even talk about because i know like some of them are not public so
yeah well if you have a good example okay i do have the link it's public there's a blog post so
we'll link it in the description if you haven't seen it that's great but um joel you we we got off
topic there the one that i'm trying to talk about here is the client side path traversal which is
different very notably different so don't very notably different yes um this is something that
happens in the user's browser i mentioned yeah this happens in style sheets but it also happens in js
files and it can also happen just in in fetch and ajax requests right so requests that are being sent
by the page via javascript and those are very impactful as well because if you can traverse in a
context where it's trying to like let's say it's sending a post request to like you know load your
news feed or whatever right if you can control that path and you can hit it you know make it hit like
slash delete account and that delete account doesn't require any you know parameters then you can force
user to just delete their account i've found this bug before um and so definitely be on the lookout
there's a lot of different implications it can result in um css injection it can result in xss it can
result in um this sort of c surf sort of outcome um and then the other thing that i i don't know how much of an
issue this still is but um there used to be this thing called 401 injection where you can inject a
uh you know a prompt where it would pop up and they would ask the user to type in their credentials
right and then that prompt was actually coming from your website but it was on the page that
uh you know you injected into um that used to be a bug i don't i i didn't get a chance to check it
before this episode to see whether it's still active or not but um if that could also be a potential
outcome from these sort of uh client-side path traversal if you can find an open redirect and
redirect to your own site where you serve a 401 yeah i do wonder if that's still a thing i remember that
that class of vulnerability but i don't actually know know if it's still accessible that's that's with
like uh realm like authentication stuff right yeah yeah and i'm i'm pretty confident it's it's possible
in at least one of the major browsers i just can't remember which one it is so we'll have to check that
out i've got some good guesses and it's probably not chrome yes it's definitely not chrome cool all
right next one cookie bombing have you have you heard of have you heard of cookie bombing slash do you
do cookie bombing joel i i before i get put on the list here uh so i i hadn't real i the i'd heard of
the name and i understand like the concept um but until i actually read through file descriptors um
slides about this specifically now it definitely clicks and i would kind of tie it in with the next
one that we were going to talk about which is cookie jar overflow but basically these two classes are
um exploiting just like sort of native browser behavior around how cookies are set and sent and
so oftentimes there have been new security features that have been added to like how cookies work for
example http only um or site secure or whatever um and that make it so that they're only accessible
within certain contexts and they're only sent within certain contexts and you know if it's http only then
your JavaScript can't read and write it but that's fine because sometimes you control a web server
that is doing that over http instead of doing that over javascript and so with cookie bombing for
example you can set multiple cookies for the same host on different paths and when they get sent the
browser doesn't distinguish whether or not you know oftentimes well maybe it does well i mean i mean
it's supposed to the paths the paths piece um you can use the different paths to bomb specific
endpoints so like you said you know the the this is abusing a sort of browser level problem with cookie
management which is if you send too many cookies uh it the browser will still send them to the to
the server but the server will sort of i guess this is sort of a server-side issue then the server is
going to freak out and be like okay whoa whoa this request is way too big please please stop right and
it's gonna i forget what status code it sends it's it's some 400 status code um but it freaks out and
it doesn't like that right um and so you can set you know you can set enough cookies that the browser
will happily send along which essentially das is your access to a specific website until you delete your
cookies right um and you literally do that just by setting all right cookie one equals 9999 a's cookie two
equals 999 a's you know and then like do that until you've blown up the whole request right and um and
that will result in the whatever user's browser you're you're setting this in uh not being able to
access the target the target website until they clear their cookies um and this can be particularly
tricky here's here's a here's a fun one here if you do this on a sub part of a website that is not the top
url because what people will do sometimes is they can't access the website they'll delete the cookies
for the specific website that they're on right which is their top url but let's say use for example
you cookie bombed the api.domain right the api.domain.com the that's never in the user's top level
browser so if they try to delete their cookies for that website then they can't do it right without
without going in there and actually deleting all of their cookies which is kind of a pain in the ass because
it it logs you out of literally every single website yeah um so this is this is a really cool
vulnerable and you can do this with just a gadget that sets allows you to inject a cookie on the
website which is fairly common um and this is also a great way for you to um show uh an effect to
availability uh which ups your cbss score um and it really helps with like stuff like subdomain
takeovers to show impact yeah yeah there's actually a cool tool idea just thought of right now as we're
saying that which would be something that basically you could plug in your existing cbss score or maybe like
say you have a bug and it meets certain criteria within cbss and then the tool would tell you if
you could get that if you could change this one factor it would take your bug from a medium to a
high or a medium to a crit or something that's a great idea so so you'd have you could put in your cbss
score and then it'll tell you okay your easiest escalations are going to be all right if you can
figure out how to affect availability just a little bit you know maybe try cookie bombing or something like
that dude that's a great idea someone's got to build that yeah yeah uh not us though yeah i got too
much going on yeah critical thinking community please please take that and run with it somebody make
that too even if it takes four years big work yeah at big work uh no that's great um and the other
thing that i was going to say um specifically on app cache i mean um on cookie bombing is you can use
it with stuff as well like like app cache um because what will happen if you define an app cache on a
specific page uh if there's an error that occurs at the browser level uh it will sub in a different
content so it's perfect for cookie bombing and i've seen this i've seen franz abuse this i've seen
file descriptor abuse this and he actually mentions it in his talk entitled the cookie monster in your
browsers which i think was the talk you were mentioning earlier um and he also mentions how
you can use it to get it to not consume a loth tokens because you can cookie bomb the specific a loth
end point right yeah that was like such an interesting attack vector so yeah i guess if you basically
cookie bomb and it sets too many cookies the request will fail but the request the outbound request will
still contain like the credentials or whatever in the url and so you can because it's like a failed
request it doesn't hit like iframe options i guess is that correct well so there there's some there's
some intricacies like that but the one the one that's really you know how helpful in this scenario is
like and it can help you avoid iframe options and some csp stuff as well but in this scenario you you're
when as soon as that that code lands on the page where the callback is it gets used and consumed
right so even if you have a reference to that window and within xss or something like you can't
consume you can't get to that token in time because it's gonna you're gonna lose the race every time
and it's gonna consume the last token and you can't get account takeover but if you cookie bomb the
endpoint where that oauth code is getting returned to when it goes to that page it's gonna fail
but you because you're the same origin you can still reach into that page grab the you know um
window location dot href and pull the code out of there which would allow you to get escalate your
xss to atl it's just such a great technique i love it yeah that's awesome yeah yeah um on cookie so
then like tendential yeah the cookie jar overflow which is kind of similar in like sending too many
cookies or like yeah sort of overflowing how the browser is behaving but you actually have a whole
tool for this which i did not know about called check cookie jar overflow i yeah i don't know what
it's what you call it but it's a link on your on your domain yeah it's a link apps.renorator.dev you
guys can check it out this is just kind of it's just kind of like if you click on it it's kind of
like just a scrappy little website with like a freaking um apache you know yeah it's it's literally
20 20 lines of html including the script and essentially um what it allows so i actually before
prepping for this episode i was like all right let me you know i was for this episode i'm like you
know i i'm gonna drop some knowledge i'm gonna you know show them all these cool like weird esoteric
web bones and then i get in there and i and i was researching for cookie bombing and i find this
cookie jar overflow thing i'm like what the heck is that i've never even heard of that and so i found
it and i think it was on the site hacker yeah hack tricks that tricks which is really cool like
that's a great website by the way um yeah did we talk about this last episode too we might have but
what hack tricks yeah yeah but again this is like one of those like informational type documentation
websites that we talked about where this type of resource is something that like keep it in your
bookmarks and just like if you're ever stuck on something check all of the ones that you have bookmarked
because oftentimes there'll be some like weird edge stuff or just some like really interesting
techniques that somebody has documented somewhere that you can take advantage of to escalate your
vulnerability to the next level yeah there's so many awesome like just weird things in this hack
tricks dot xyz um website so i'll do my best to sort of go in and digest some of that and and put it up
back into the podcast um in an auditory format but when i was prepping for the the
the like for the cookie bombing i ran across this cookie jar overflow which is really cool and i
actually um had i known about this um at the last life hacking event i would have been able to save a
friend a lot of time because he had to go uh down this this path to get rid of this cookie that he needed
to be gone um and uh he could have just used this technique um and it would have just he would have
been able to get it gone in just a second so the technique just to be clear is um you essentially
just set a bunch of cookies in the browser for a specific domain and each domain has a limit on how
many cookies can be associated with it in the browser that's the cookie jar and the cookie jar limit
um and so if you if you exceed that limit cookies start getting deleted oldest first so you can edge
out the other cookies in the user's browser even if you don't know the name of that cookie so let's
say for example you have a cookie um you know session uh auth session xyz random string equals whatever
their session token is right you don't know what that random string is so you can't overwrite that cookie
and if it's hdp only cookie you can't access it from the javascript side even if you can set cookies right
so you need that cookie gone so you can do a session fixation um and how do you how are you gonna get
rid of it because you don't know the name of it right so um this is a cool technique you can use to
do that by setting a bunch of cookies overflowing the cookie jar and then being able to use your own
values um and one of the things i thought was really interesting is you can edge out http only cookies
even from a non-htp only context which i think is really cool and seems like a little bit of an issue right
yeah well i mean and again this is like weird behavior that's kind of intended but also not
intended like yeah you know it it abuses like one two functionalities that both need to exist at the
same time and they kind of collide with each other tangentially right where it's like http only
shouldn't be able to be set by javascript but if you set a bunch of other cookies with javascript
eventually you'll have too many cookies and the http only cookies will just get removed and like yeah you
know that what the browser is going to just have an infinite memory no like you can't right so like
these two things have to both exist and there's no real easy compromise there so it's super super
interesting behavior and one of those things that you know have it documented keep it in the back of
your brain and then when you need it you'll have it yeah for sure so we'll add some links down below the
little um sort of tool that i that you mentioned before that you saw in the doc that was just something that i
sort of scraped together to help people understand where their cookie jar overflow limit is in the browser
so you guys can check it out we'll link it down below it's apps.rionrader.dev/cookie
or slash check cookie jar overflow.html in camel case of course so you know probably easier to just
click the link you're welcome just click the link in the description yeah um but essentially if you go to
that and you click on it it will set a bunch of cookies and tell you where your cookie jar limit
is in your browser um i ran it in chrome in prep for this episode and it puts it at 180 cookies
um the range for this is between i think 150 to 180 but every time i've run it i've gotten 180.
so um yeah you know you should be able to do it pretty easily yeah and maybe as some off off the
pod research i would be curious if this matters more uh like the length of the cookie if that matters
at all or if it's just purely number of cookies do you know i think it's just pure number of cookies
because i was just setting let me take a look at the code really quickly here you say off the pod research
and then you know we're gonna do it right away yeah we're gonna look right now yeah no it's just
it's just you know check and then the index equals the index so i'm just saying check one equals one
check two equals two and that sort of thing and it's overflowing at 180 so i i think i think it's just
a number of cookies thing cool cool yeah awesome all right next one dude um this one is cross-site leak
um yeah sort of similar to c-surf um it's a little bit less common um and i think it is going to be
a uh i think it will be an increasingly um common vulnerability over the next couple years um i've
seen a couple people exploit this uh successfully at live hacking events and i've seen it result in a
critical once um and essentially the concept of it is well it's sort of like a c-surf right in that
you're forcing the user to have uh may have their browser make a request but instead of having an
action performed on behalf of the user using some sort of side channel whether it be the number of
frames on the resulting page or an error you know 200 or 404 you can determine whether or not the user is
uh in some sort of state some state um and so you can determine you know something about the user's
presence in the application uh based off of that um and so there's a couple techniques that you can use
for this here um one of the ones that i think is really cool is frame counting so essentially you can
open up a a new tab in in a window and one of the few things that you can access cross um cross uh
origin right when you're reaching into a different frame um is the uh frames length uh attribute on a
window so you can see how many sub sub frames are in the application so let's say you submit a um a
search into some sort of cross-site search functionality where you've got a query parameter
you know equals whatever and if there are results then there will be another iframe on the page maybe
they'll show you like a preview of the results or something like that if there aren't results then
there won't be an iframe and you can use that difference along with the frame length trick to
determine whether or not that user has access to whatever thing you're searching for in the browser
which can result in a in a pretty interesting leak of information i think yeah yeah it's super
interesting i had never heard of this technique at all um there's a whole domain for it xs leaks.dev
and it basically just goes over like a lot of the different like browser features and tricks
and nuances and defense mechanisms for the other side as well um and yeah this is a really useful
research i'm gonna i definitely put this in my bookmarks um and i was just really you know it's
cool to see this type of again this type of more like informational research that's documenting like
strange behaviors things that exist things that you might be able to use to chain with your existing
vulnerabilities to make them more impactful um yeah it's really interesting i think a lot of
companies care about leakage of data even if it's an oracle type thing like this is yeah and it's
definitely a useful i've had some companies say no to that before you know i've had like some oracle
related stuff like you know is this user an admin or is this user you know a member of a specific
organization or something like that um i think those i think those could definitely be helpful in attack
chains but you definitely got to realize when you're submitting these sort of bugs that um it is
sort of a risk you know um so definitely keep that in mind um one of the things that i did think of
well first let me let me talk about some of the ways you can exploit this so we talked about frame
counting right that's that technique where you can um determine the number of sub excuse me sub frames
on a window object there's also another one that this is really cool uh joel i thought you'd appreciate
this one because i had never seen this one before um you can actually count the history dot length
um and it can release information so what happens is you're on an attackers page user clicks a button
you open up a new tab right the user is in that new tab you're distracting the user in the previous tab
um you can iterate through um some you can go to some url and if that url redirects it will take you to a
third url right and then you can redirect back to using the window object you can redirect back to the
the main page so now you're on the same origin between the two pages and you check the history dot length
and it will tell you how many you know changes in the history have occurred since you know you you
check the history dot length um and so that's another way that you can sort of leak really cool
um sort of side channel stuff and i'm not sure how like how this could be used um this could definitely
be used in a way to tell if a user is a part of an organization or not that's definitely something
that's possible um uh but yeah i'm really interested to hear you know what other stuff people comes up
with uh using this technique because i think i think there are definitely possibilities for it
yeah yeah i think as browsers get more hardened we're gonna have to get a little more creative with
these types of techniques that we're talking about because some of the things that we took for granted
as way ways to easily escalate bugs like before http only just being able to read all the cookies
from javascript right like that's not a thing anymore so now you have to figure out more
creative ways to get information about the user or infer different states and and all that kind
of stuff so yeah um it's really awesome to see this type of research and even in the era of same
site cookies as well you know we've had that restriction come in place now um yeah there's
we're even having to get more more creative using window.open rather than using iframes and such
so we're losing some of this flexibility but um the last one that i think is really interesting
sort of a cross-site leak technique that i found out was if you open up
a pdf in chrome okay it will provide you with a post message based interface
for that pdf even cross origin so i was thinking this would be a really cool technique um an attack
vector okay let's say you've got an application that has a customer um you know you can in click you
know go to a specific url and it will load up a pdf for that specific customer right and that's a numeric id
so you know once again you do the window.open trick and then you start iterating through customer ids
right if and you can tell whether it's a pdf or not via this post message interaction so now you're
iterating through iterating through iterating through and you can tell how many customers a given person
has by whether the response is a pdf or not via this cross-site leak and i think that's definitely some
impactful stuff um for sure you know being able to tell whether or not you know their customer how
at what pace their customer base is increasing um yeah so that's another cool technique there that i
didn't know about the the pdf thing uh exposing a post message listener that's kind of crazy yeah yeah
that that competitive intelligence stuff is is pretty valuable to a lot of companies yeah cool
all right sorry for ranting on that one no no no that's totally fine i love cross-site leaks i think
that's such a cool type of vulnerability i don't even know where you found this domain it's it's really
cool yeah yeah all right so the next one unc path leaks you want to take that or should i
oh yeah i can talk a little bit about it but um so unc what is the universal network convention naming
convention um basically it's like the paths that you see on typically on windows where it's like
backslash backslash something um and so oftentimes you can inject into these in like a ton of different
places um it'll be maybe in like a file inclusion or maybe it'll be a path traversal or a desktop application
yeah desktop application or something like that that has that's running again typically on windows
um but it's a really good way to escalate and sort of pivot and navigate horizontally within a system
that maybe you can escalate that vertically but oftentimes it's going to be pivoting to other
services or systems or network drives or something like that that are accessible within the host that you
can then take to your advantage to really prove the impact of your of your bug and just showing that
you can interact with stuff outside of that application or within other parts of the network
is already like a really big impact provider so um you know yeah very very along the same lines as
like path path traversal path injection that type of stuff but yeah was there specific things you wanted
to mention yeah well the other thing that i wanted to mention is like the use of repeater with this
so let's say for example you have a um a deep link you can provide to a windows desktop app and that will
open up you know some file of your choice right you can provide it with a unc path there um which is a
path to link to us to a specific server and a share you on that server right so what will happen by default is
windows will try to authenticate into that share and it will send your ntlm v2 hash um to that server even
though it's not in the local network it doesn't happen you know it could be anywhere um and you
can use a tool called excuse me a tool called repeater to catch that and pull the hash um that'll leak a
couple things to you one it'll leak the username of the um server whoever's uh you know using that
specific whoever's making that connection so if on the desktop app it would be you know the user of the
of the pc on an actual server when you've got like an ssrf sort of thing that would be the server username
and then also the ntlm v2 hash of that user which one is a password hash um that you can crack offline
so that could definitely be helpful for proving impact um and i believe there are some cool things
you can do with ntlm v2 hashes as well that's beyond just password cracking but i have to research into
that but i know for sure that you can then take that password and crack it offline which is a pretty
helpful way to increase your ability to pivot within that network yeah totally this is one of those
things that's a little bit outside of my realm of like familiar knowledge like network pen testing stuff
yeah exactly it's more like uh you know you're doing like a network pen test and you know you
found some vulnerable windows image or instance or something like that um more kind of on the like
the metasploit type route not that that's like a bad thing but like more like there are there's
lots of tools and stuff that are built around this type of stuff and typically the type of hacking
that we're doing is like web hacking or like yeah mobile hacking maybe hardware hacking but generally
not like internal pen test type stuff where the ntlm hashes are going to be leaked um but i think
there's a huge body of resource uh resources and research out there that covers this type of
information and how to exploit um ntlm hashes and what to do with them i know mimi cats is a pretty
popular tool um for that type of stuff so yeah the um so i think it's it's very important to have this
sort of cross-discipline um yeah knowledge though because you know we've seen especially in the
desktop app exploitation arena which is something we see in bug bounty a decent bit still um i've seen
this bug you know result this little quirk result in uh much higher bounties for some of the desktop
level applications um because you know uh understandably uh software providers don't
want to be responsible for leaking their users ntlm v2 hash to whoever um so keep that in mind if
you're doing any desktop level hacking whether it be you know um electron based stuff for native
clients or whatever yeah because again like this is like a pivot from application vulnerability to os
problem right where like if your application is leaking a hash to the os user you've now compromised
that whole user within the entire os it's no longer about your application it's about the entire user
and if their system is exposed at all now you can use those credentials to gain access to their system
even further and like totally exploit the user beyond the application and the implications of just that
application so i think it's a huge impact provider if you can figure out a way to exploit it effectively
yeah absolutely okay um let's let's have this next one be the last one here um i entitled this one
impactful link hijack um because we've seen some link hijacking vulnerabilities and stuff like that pop
up on the activity you know in the past that are kind of crappy that are just like yeah you know you're
you're looking over your instagram on your home page yeah oh somebody forgot to you know refresh this
domain or whatever and that that's kind of like okay you know i feel like that's more of a qa issue or
like a web design team issue you know it's less of a security issue but there is a specific um
subset of these issues call that i i just deem impactful link hijacking um which um when is when
this sort of thing happens in the ci flow within within source code excuse me man this cold is really
getting the better of me yeah it's funny because over the last like 55 minutes or so you've progressively
gotten more and more like someone who smokes six packs of cigarettes a day yeah dude yeah that's the
struggle with having a podcast is like oh man i gotta get on here and talk every single week with my
voice um finally all those meetings are are putting me to good use yeah exactly so so yeah just the thing
that i wanted people to take away with this one thing is like if you can go to a github repo and like
find a script that's being curled or or um find a a old domain that's being reached out to or like an
s3 bucket s3 buckets are really common heroku instances that sort of thing and you're able to inject
yourself either in the ci pipeline or in the source code um uh you know context then there can be some
really impactful vulnerabilities there um yeah i am not doing as much github scanning anymore i used
to be pretty big on the github scanning because uh but since they sort of started cracking down on that
sort of thing i i've i you know various secrets being linked and that sort of thing i've i've spent less
time there but i know for a fact that people are still finding very impactful vulnerabilities
via you know finding um expired domains or s3 buckets or hogan instances or whatever inside of
source code and ci pipelines yep yeah and in addition to that um it doesn't have to be within
like a script automatically if you want to provide an impact so like who i was hacking with a couple
weeks ago um he found a really interesting bug that was basically exactly this where there was a set of
instructions that were in a github repo for how to set up a tool and those instructions included a bunch of
set of commands and in those set of commands it was pulling down a resource from an s3 bucket
and that s3 bucket didn't exist and he was able to take over the s3 bucket and prove impact by saying
look this is in the readme if somebody were to copy paste this which is completely a plausible scenario
they would be pulling resources down from my bucket and you know it was accepted so i think like
that's just like a great example of like one it doesn't have to be directly in a script but like
just the fact that they're using it and they're advocating for you like the user to be pulling
something from that resource if that resource doesn't exist anymore that's direct impact because they're
they're explicitly telling you hey use this domain well that domain is no longer safe so i think like
anything like down that sort of path is a is a good way to to have impactful link hijacking right it
doesn't always have to be like i took over your instagram username or whatever like i think that
stuff exists as well for uh open source code and open source scripts and all that kind of stuff that you
that you mentioned yeah for sure man all right i think that's that's a wrap that's seven um you know
esoteric web vulnerability types hopefully y'all learned something from that i i definitely did
while researching for it um if you guys wouldn't mind definitely head over to ctbb.show
drop your email in the newsletter subscription there that would be a big help to us and uh yeah anything
else you got joel before we sign off no i think that's it i'm uh i've got a bunch of new bookmarks and
tools to download yeah so same the same man i'm gonna go play around with that big park
short skin tool right after this yeah awesome all right hopefully hopefully your your voice
and your your cold goes away and uh hopefully you feel a little better but i'll see you next week
thanks man yeah hopefully i'll be recovered for next week all right cool peace peace